sergeant you were in the one-eight with
me
though you were significantly
fatter sir they called me cherry titties
because i had large uh titties yes i
remember
i never liked that nickname though to be
fair it was
accurate hey how's cold turkey going
uh-huh
i heard chewing gum helps you know i
never smoked but i did once have an
addiction
food it got bad
you're not closed it's six o'clock i
need my moose you park
i need my machine
yeah baby i can pick up the crib right
after i get the groceries and before i
start painting the nursery
i can draw a cloud i don't need a
stencil okay
i'll get the stencil look i don't know
when i'll be home i'll text you okay
oh all this paperwork is gonna straight
up kill me
how are you so chipper oh simple i hate
a cacao nib
every time i close a case a what a cacao
nib
they're these happy little chocolaty
delights from deep in the peruvian
rainforest yeah try one
do i look like a man who snacks you look
like eight circles with suspenders on
but these aren't bad for you they're
full of fiber and antioxidants
go ahead keep trying okay fine
just one mm-hmm
damn these are good plus you're organic
and fair trade
terry loves responsible agricultural
practices
case closed what time is it that's right
it's never clock oh new case
new nib red 20 words
that's a new hmm that nibble's kind of
small
hey sarge you may want to slow down on
those things
things these are the precious jewels of
the rainforest boy
i don't mean to overstep here but you're
looking a little
fat oh boy
how dare you you can't comment on my
body
this is a workplace now i'm feeling
objectified by your male gaze
absolutely not sir just listen yo i
don't want to listen boyle you are
trying to shame me and that will not fly
okay now i need some more nibs just to
calm down
i thought you should know i heard what
you said and it really sank in
i'm off the news really of course
i'm terry jeffords and when i put my
mind to something
i do it my resting heart rate
is six six spoiled you know the rest of
you
could learn a little something from me
sure sometimes we fall down
but it's how we get back up that matters
we need to look our feelings in the
eye and say not today
not today nibs
oh sergeants
fine i'm not better
these nibs are just too damn delicious i
don't think the nibs being too
yummy is the problem i think right now
there's too much on your plate
metaphor intended you're stress eating
that's even worse
the stress isn't going anywhere i'm
about to have my third kid
and they just get more stressful over
time man oh
nibs what am i gonna do help me
[Music]
sarge i uh i know you have every right
to be stressed out
new kid on the way sharon's on bed rest
global warming
this preamble is making me nibby get you
the point
i got the squad to volunteer a little
bit of their off time to help you and
your family out
i'll make dinner once a week everybody
else volunteered babysitting time and
hitchcock offered massage sessions
for your wife what so i pepper sprayed
him
you're a good man child how can i ever
thank you
start taking care of yourself again i
miss those gross overly large muscles
lay off my body dude i clearly got some
stuff to work through
i get what you're saying but at least i
used to be a prime physical specimen
dude you have like one percent body fat
now i'm at 1.8 i'm fat i'm a fat bald
man
you